allen kim
stole the show at the 93rd annual oscars
before the show even started
the minari star who turned nine years
old on saturday
walked the red carpet on sunday like a
hollywood pro
with his producer christina oh by his
side
yep that's the young star rocking a
custom tom brown shorts tuxedo
complete with a bow tie and knee-high
socks
posing like a boss and if that wasn't
cute enough
cameras also caught alan doing a cute
little jig
but before the actor hit the red carpet
he shared these
chic snaps walking his dog on instagram
alongside the caption quote it's time
for the oscars
but first i have to walk cream now it's
off to the show
allen made his film debut playing david
in minari
[Music]
and last month it was with alan shortly
after
his win for best young actor at the 2021
critics choice awards
well in your speech you said is this a
dream does it feel like a dream
does all of this feel like a a crazy
dream to you or do you know
this is really happening a crazy dream
and he opened up about getting emotional
during his acceptance speech
alan oh my goodness your speech tonight
had me and just about everyone else in
tears
what was making you cry i'm not sure if
i
actually had a reason to cry i just
cried
who's in the house with you and who was
there with you when you were giving your
speech
my mom my dad my sister and my dog that
had to be special to have the moment
with mom and with your whole family
yep what did mom and dad and everybody
say to you tonight
they cry mostly everybody cried huh
except my dog my dog's like what
is going on why is everybody crying
it seems like his pup is always by his
side
in fact when instagram asked alan what
his dream movie would be he shared
this trailer about an epic journey to
rescue his best friend
cream who was stolen by an evil magician
i know there is no love interest don't
even think about it
you